THE BORDER CRISIS.
BUT FIRST MY OPEN.
SINCE I VISITED THE BORDER A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO A LOT HAS
HAPPENED.
TENS OF THOUSANDS MORE ILLEGALS
AND UNACCOMPANIED MINORS ENTERED
THE COUNTRY.
BORDER PATROL IS EVEN MORE
INUNDATED THAN THEY WERE TWO
WEEKS AGO.
WHEN THE RARE INDIVIDUALS WHERE
BEING TESTED, THEY HAVE A 10%
COVID POSITIVE RATE.
NO SURPRISE GIVEN THE PICTURES
WE SEE OF IMMIGRANTS LITERALLY
WITHIN INCHES OF EACH OTHER
TRAVELING IN LARGE GROUPS IN
MANY COUNTRIES ARE BEING SENT
INTO THE INTERIOR OF THE UNITED
STATES TO A TOWN OR VILLAGE NEAR
YOU.
WE HEAR OF TEACHERS NOW, THE
SALES -- THE SAME ONES REFUSING
TO TEACH OUR CHILDREN,
VOLUNTEERING TO THESE THE
MIGRANTS CHILDREN.
THE WORK OF THE CARTELS AND THE
COYOTES CONTINUES AS THEY
INHUMANELY TRAFFIC CHILDREN AND
YOUNG GIRLS IN THE DANGEROUS
TREK FROM THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE.
THIS WEEK IN A TESTAMENT TO
THEIR BRUTALITY, WE SAW COYOTES
LITERALLY THROW TWO LITTLE
GIRLS, AGES 3 AND 5 OVER THE
14-FOOT BORDER FENCE IN THE
DESERT MILES FROM THE NEAREST
RESIDENCE.
IT’S THE VIDEO OF SMUGGLERS
ABANDONING LITTLE GIRLS AND
LEAVING THEM FOR WHATEVER
NATURAL OR HUMAN PRESENTED CORES
WHO MIGHT FIND THEM.
FORTUNATELY, BORDER PATROL AGAIN
HAS COME TO THE AID OF THOSE
VICTIMS.
AS THE CRISIS EXPLODES ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, THE AMAZING
PART IS PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
REFUSING TO EVEN VISIT THE
REGION TO SEE HOW THIS POLICIES
HAVE DAMAGED AND CONTINUE TO
DAMAGE OUR NATION.
IN A MOVE THAT’S ALMOST
HUMOROUS, HE PASSED OFF THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO KAMALA HARRIS
WHO SEES HUMOR IN EVERYTHING.
FOR HER PART SHE REFUSED TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
BORDER.
WHEN ASKED IF SHE WOULD VISIT
THE BORDER, THIS WAS HER
RESPONSE.
>> DO YOU PLAN TO VISIT THE
BORDER?
>> HM ... NOT TODAY.
BUT I HAVE BEFORE AND I’M SURE I
WILL GEANL [LAUGHTER]
JUDGE JEANINE: WHY DOES SHE
ALWAYS LAUGH WHEN SHE IS ASKED
SERIOUS QUESTIONS?
SHE COMPARED I.C.E. AGENTS AND
ESSENTIAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO THE KLU KLUX KLAN.
A LITTLE WHITE HOUSE INTRIGUE.
A SENIOR AIDE FOR KAMALA TOLD
REPORTERS THE VICE PRESIDENT
WOULD NOT BE DOING THE BORDER,
AND I INSTEAD SHE WOULD BE
TACKLING THE POLICY ISSUES,
FOCUSING ON THE ROOT CAUSES OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
ESSENTIALLY REMOVING HER FROM
ANY BLAME FOR THE DISASTER AT
THE BORDER.
WE DON’T NEED HER TO HEAD A
COMMISSION OR STUDY TO DETERMINE
THE ROOT CAUSE.
THE ROOT CAUSE IS CLEAR.
IT’S THE BIDEN-HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THEIR
RECKLESS POLICY.
JANUARY 20 THEY SWUNG AMERICA’S
DOORS OPEN TO ANYONE WHO WANTS
TO ENTER INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THE INVITATION WAS CLEAR.
EVEN MEXICAN PRESIDENT OBRADOR
REFERRED TO JOE BIDEN AS THE
QUOTE MIGRANT PRESIDENT.
HE PLACES BLAME SOLELY ON THE
SHOULDERS OF JOE BIDENS
SPECIALLY BECAUSE JOE BIDEN
CANCELED THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY AGREED UPON BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND THE MEXICAN PRESIDENT.
NOT ONLY IS THIS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS BECAUSE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION’S INABILITY OR
REFUSAL TO TEST MIGRANTS BEFORE
SHIPPING THEM ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
NOT ONLY IS IT A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS BECAUSE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION’S DECISION TO
PLACE CHILDREN IN INHUMANE AND
BARBARIC CONDITIONS.
AND THOSE ARE ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ’S WORDS.
THIS IS A CRISIS.
WE ARE A SOVEREIGN NATION AND WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHO IS COMING INTO
THIS COUNTRY.
THE SHARE RIVER DAMAGE SAID
100,000 HAVE ENTERED ALONG HIS
SECTOR.
THEY ARE COMING FROM TURKEY AND
IRAN AND YES MEN AND 138
OTHER -- COUNTRIES.
>> THE PEOPLE COMING FROM YEMEN
AND SRI LANKA AND TURKEY.
IT’S DIFFERENT THAN IT WAS.
JUDGE JEANINE: 90% OF THE DRUGS
THAN COME INTO OUR COUNTRY COMES
THROUGH THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
FENTANYL IS COMING THROUGH IN AN
AMOUNT LARGE ENOUGH TO TAKE DOWN
AN ENTIRE AMERICAN CITY.
HE WEEK THE NIGHTMARE BACKS
BIGGER AND GREATER AND MORE
DIRE.
STAY TUNED, IT WILL ONLY GET
WORSE.
THAT’S MY OPEN.
LET ME KNOW WHAT YOU THINK ON